quel est le plus gros youtubeur français
à l'heure où nous parlons Squeezie bah
Squeezie si tu vas sur sa chaîne et ben
tu tomberas sur des vidéos de Squeezie
quand il l'avais 14 ans donc aussi je
voulais vous dire des choses très
importantes euh pour les épisodes sa et
ces vidéos étaient Nules il savait
peut-être pas lui-même ce qu'il voulait
faire mais il y avait une intention et
cette intention elle n'a fait que se
développer par la pratique c'est-à-dire
qu'à chaque fois même de manière
insensible c'était un petit peu mieux tu
sais c'est comme quand tu apprends à
conduire il faut savoir ce que c'est que
de caler pour comprendre ce qui se passe
quand tu passes ta première c'estàd
qu'il faut en passer par l'erreur par
l'échec par la colère pour ensuite
pouvoir nettoyer tout ce qui ne va pas
donc il vaut mieux faire des erreurs
même en sachant que ce sont des erreurs
mais on avancera quand même plus vite
qu'en voulant éliminer les erreurs avant
d'avoir commencé j'ai toujours constaté
que c'était par la pratique qu'on
s'améliorit et c'est bien d'avoir un peu
honte de ce qu'on a fait au début parce
que c'est la preuve qu'on a parcouru du
chemin